صباح العربيه مشاهدينا متواجده اليوم
لتنقل لكم اجواء هذا الحفل المميز كما
ترون الان بدات بوابات الدخول باستقبال
جمهور من محبي الفنانه احلام في مسرح ابو
بكر سالم في بوليفارد سيتي
نعم خصيصا الفناناتنا الفنانه العرب احلام
وهذا اقل شيء نقدر ندعمها من بلادنا انا
من الشرقيه وجايه اليوم مخصوص عشان احضر
حفله احلام انا وبنتي كنت استناها بطارق
الصبر من زمان والحمد لله ربي حققها لي
انا جاي من الخبر سعيد اليوم متواجد في
مسرح ابو بكر سالم لحضور حفله فناننا
العرب احلام وان شاء الله راح نستمتع فيها
واحلام دائما غنيه جدا جدا جميله بصراحه
انا مره متحمسه على حفله احلام بالذات كنت
انتظرها من اول
فاكيد ان شاء الله راح تكون حفله فوق
الخيال يشهد الان الحفل تفاعلا كبيرا من
الحضور
[موسيقى]
نشدها الان في هذه اللحظه ليلى
احنا دائما يكون عندنا فكره احنا اليوم
سوينا الليله الماسيه الناس يفتكرون ان
انا سويت الليله الماسيه عشان اقول احلام
المطربه الماسيه انا سويت عشان اقول ان
الرياض هي ماسه الوطن العربي حفل اليوم
الحمد لله ممتاز وترتيب رائع واحلام اليوم
وابدعتنا بالجوال البارده هذه احنا لما
نسمع ملكه احلام
وعند ما شفته جماهيريه رائعه لها
كاريزما الملكه احلام مختلفه تماما فنانه
العرب فعلا يعني انا ضاعت علي رحله وحجزت
على الرحله اللي بعده واستنيت في المطار
والاجواء بارده بس بندبه بندفه بصوت ام
فهد طبعا
الناس انا حاسه ان انا برا المجره في حته
تانيه
[موسيقى]
اقول اشكر فهد على موقفها الجميل واشكر من
كل من دعمني وصلني لوفائات لهذه الحفله
جميله وليله جميله وفهد وفت في كلامها
وعدتني وعدتني انا غنيت معها وانت تشوفون
الشعور ما ينصف يعني الفنانه احلام الملكه
متواجده يكفي الحضور اللي نشوفه وراء الان
شيء جدا جدا يشكرون عليه الجمهور الفنان
احلام تستاهل هذا الحضور صراحه حتى لو انه
برد شوفي انا وش لابس واحد يمين وواحده
يسار مستحملين البرد الله يعطيها العافيه
والله ليلى ماسيه مميزه بحسنها وضربها
استمتع فيها جمهور فنانه العرب احلام
العنود العبدلي لصباح العربيه الرياض